Hey, what's up guys happy New Year, this is the first video of 2017
I've had a lot of awesome comments come through asking if I died or if I got arrested
But as you can see, I'm still here working in my lab, in fact I've been working my lab every single day making new videos
For you. I am literally making liquid nitrogen right now. So why haven't I been posting them?
Well, I'll tell you all about that in a minute first of all
I want to give you a couple of really exciting updates seven and a half million subscribers is coming up very fast
So I'm going to be giving away an Xbox one to show my appreciation so watch for that contest coming soon
Yeah, and every time we hit milestones like 8 million, 9 million, 10 million subscribers
I'm going to give away things like Macbook laptops and video cameras to enable you to start making videos for yourself
You rock, and you know that. If you're following me on Instagram or Facebook you've probably seen a lot of the updates on projects
I have been working on. I give sneak peeks and previews on Instagram and Facebook so links are in the description if you want to
See what I'm doing these days. the instagram stories only last 24 hours though, so if you didn't see what I was doing yesterday
It's probably already too late, but if you start following me on Instagram now, you'll see everything I do in the future
so here's the thing guys, mid-november, I tried a personal experiment just to see if I could post a video every single day
It's not something. I've ever been able to do before, and definitely something I couldn't do by myself
so I hired one of my friends to help me do the filming and the editing and every single day
We worked sunup to sundown pulling all-nighters and often stay up until 4:00 and 5:00 in the morning to get a video prepped and ready
For release going to bed for a few hours and then getting up and doing it all over again
Along with the contests the descriptions the annotations and everything else that goes with releasing a video
This is by far one of the most challenging and taxing personal experiments
I've taken on in quite a while and while you guys were opening presents on Christmas morning
I was still editing videos getting them ready for release the next day so after a month and a half of editing and putting out
videos every day with no sleep my left eye started twitching. So once Christmas ended, I decided to scale back
Take a little bit of a break let my eye heal up and put some systems into place because what I found out through this
Experiment is I really like posting videos every day
I Love being able to read your comments and the next day put out a video responding to them
But there's a lot of back-end work a lot of production a lot of things that go into making a video that you don't see
That makes it very difficult to turn them around that quickly especially ones that we're trying to make good quality so right now
I'm bringing on some people to help me
I'm training them and I'm going to get back into a groove where I can continue daily posting to videos and hopefully still be able
To get a full night's sleep in the process
I don't want to stay up 'til 4:00 and 5:00 every morning editing. These systems take a lot of work to manage
It takes a little bit of time to put them in place and in
January the Revenue for making videos is cut in half because all the advertisers who are pushing for Christmas are done
Advertising so instead of posting every day right now
What I'm doing instead is putting systems in place so I can post every day later on as well as give away cool prizes to all
You guys supporting me on YouTube and Instagram and give away more cool prizes every time we hit those subscriber Milestones
10 million is not far away guys. Can you help me do it?
Can you help me get a diamond play button so basically that's it and to recap. I am filming every single day
I've got about 14 videos right now and I film just waiting to be produced
I'm just not putting them out because what I really needed is help producing them so I can get a good night's sleep okay.
What's next? don't forget that in every video I post from now on I will be giving something away
That's a commitment that I've made to you every time I post, there will be a contest attached
All you have to do is look down in the comments and the very first comment pinned to the top will have a secret link
On where you can enter the giveaway.
I've already given away a ton of prizes and put the winners names on a list right here in the winner wall of fame this
shows who won the video they won it from, and the prizes that they got. It's that simple jump onto my videos in the
First 12 hours and you're qualified to win a prize yourself you have to be here in the first 12 hours
though, or the link disappears
so if you want to be part of the
Notification squad then subscribe to my channel ring the Bell and make sure you watch the video in the first 12 hours
it's really about it so guys that's it for this update and as promised if you're here in the first 12 hours there is a
link down in the description
that'll take you to a secret contest, a secret giveaway
And if you missed it, no big deal, just subscribe, ring the bell, and select to be notified for the next video
I'm running contests on every single video now
I'm doing it for you, because I love you guys, and it's one way I can give back. oh one other thing
I love your comments, especially suggestions on projects or experiments to try, so every time I use one of your suggestions
I'm going to feature your comment in the video and send you a gift card or a t-shirt for about $25
King of random shirts are Gonna be a thing too
So go ahead and try it today leave a comment with a suggestion of an experiment
You'd like to see me try you could be on your way to being twenty five bucks richer
Seriously guys. I love you. Thanks for nearly seven-and-a-half million subscribers and hopefully we're just getting started. these systems. I'm putting in place today
I'm hoping are going to carry us for the next Few Years. thanks for joining me for this video
I'll see you in the next one. Talk to you then
but, if you guys want to leave likes on my videos that'll be cool, too